Military theorists of basil Henry Ladelle hot one Slomin's is that
history too often glorifies those who are defeated in war while men may
forget the victors while the Polian and Robert E. Lee are enshrined in drama,
Wellington and grounds are almost forgotten.
He wrote this may be true for today's protagonist, a brutal military strategist,
who at a very young age,
led Rome in a series of spectacular victories against the greatest threats ever
faced by the Republic, Hannibal of Carthage.
And while Hannibal is a household name,
the life and merits of his chief Roman rival,
maybe less than known in today's biographics we will learn about Publius
Cornelius.
Skipio known for his accomplishments as Afrikanas here's a general
switch, the basil himself labeled as greater than the polio.
[Inaudible].
Yes,
Cornelius Skipio was born in the year 235 BC to a powerful patrician
family. His father,
probably a senior was a well-respected political leader and military commander.
The life of Pivotus Jr has been chronicled by several Latin and Greek
biographies, Polybius and Livy among others.
But these writers of the past have written very little about the childhood and
early teens of our protagonist.
We know that Publius may have been born versus area and section considered a
sign of future greatness. Living even reports.
The previous was conceived by his mother and to drawn sevens.
The same story was told about on exams with the grade.
So it may have been a common myth told about great generals from the boys early
teens. We only have one disputed anecdote in this story,
we learn of how probably a senior I had to drag a semi Andress Jr.
From the bed chamber of an older lady,
friends in just enough time to prevent a scandal.
So was this a common occurrence was probably as junior,
that son of the serpents, something of a precocious ladies,
man chased around Rome by a prudish father. Well,
the truth is we don't really know, but what's a great theatrical narrative.
It would certainly make puberty as junior,
as a spoiled aristocratic brat and troublemaker who slowly comes to accept his
responsibilities toward his family and his motherlands in the time of need.
And its time of need describes the catastrophe that threatened to destroy Rome.
This was the invasion of Italy by the Carthaginian general Hannibal,
at some points you may want to watch a biographics episode about who is foil
Hannibal, but well, here are the basics.
Roman Carthage had already 40 each other during the first Punic war from 264 to
241 BC catheters forces were led by a handful of generals.
One of whom was named Hammacher baka baka,
meaning the Thunderbolt in the Phoenicia language spoken by the Carthaginians
often more than two decades of fighting Carthage to Sue for peace yielding the
Island of Sicily to Rome. One generation later in the year,
219 call it the junior enforces in Spain. What led by Hannibal Barca,
the son of Hammacher or the son of the Thunderbolt Hannibal and his forces had
resumed hostilities and attacking Sagami zoom,
a Spanish city allied with Rome that kicked off the second Punic war.
Whereas most of the first conflict centered around Ireland combat and Naval
battles. Hannibal surprised Rome by taking the fight. It's a,
he made a wild gambit by leading his army of 26,000 men plus elephants over the
snowy peaks of the Alps and into the Northern portion of the Italian peninsula.
Hannibal was happy to take crazy calculated risks.
He was hell bent on avenging cartridges, previous defeat,
which had Solly the name of both his father and his country in short,
he wanted revenge.
He had the right combination of brains and brawn to get everything that he
wanted.
[Inaudible].
And 218 previous senior was one of the two consoles leading the Roman
Republic and probably his junior was barely 17.
The oldest GPO was tasked by the Roman Senate to lead an army in Northern Italy,
do oppose the incoming trips of Hannibal people. His junior,
I followed his father and was put in command of a squadron of mounts and
bodyguards. The two armies clashed in the battle of taking us river.
According to Bolivia's probably a senior was surrounded by Carthaginian cavalry
during the battle and seriously wounded, seeing this,
his sons bird on his horse and charged alone into battle.
The other cavalry men moved by his courage,
followed him into the desperate attack, coal by surprise,
the Carthaginians broke formation and fled people who are senior wounded,
but still conscious hailed his son as his savior,
the event cemented Skipio his reputation as a courageous leader,
clearly Rome was in need of men like young Skipio as Hannibal soundly defeated
the Romans on the ticket nurse and continued his March along the Italian boot,
the brilliant general thrash the Romans of the battle of trivia river.
And then again,
asked Lake transom mean we don't have any evidence that the young Skipio
participated in these battles. What can be speculated though,
is that young Skipio may have listened carefully to the accounts of these
defeats trying to learn what made Hannibal so lethal. Was it the elephants?
Sure. Hannibal had a contingent of war elephants,
which terrified and crushed the legions, or was it the cavalry?
The Carthaginians were allies of the Midians a North African group who could
boast some of the finest Calvary men of the time.
Was it animal's neck to win new allies?
General Barker was able to recruit numerous allies first among the Iberian
tribes and then among the Celtic tribes in Northern Italy. Sure.
It was all of these,
but what made Hannibal a Victor was his brilliant tactical mind,
which did not refrain from the use of stratagems trumps and ambushes to gain the
upper hand and battle.
On the other hand is the Roman Republic excelled in discipline and logistics,
but lacked tactical creativity.
They didn't even have a word for stratagems Romans considered them to be
dishonorable that's who opposing concepts of warfare would be put to the test
once more at the next big battle. On the 2nd of August, 216 BC,
the Romans and Carthaginians faced each other near the town of Canadian modern
Pulia the heel of the Italian boot had a fielded 40,000 foot and
10,000 mounted soldiers. The Romans were led by two newly elected cortisols,
Lucius Amelia's Paula's and Gaius Terentino's Varo.
They're all made was stronger, consistent of 18,000 Legionnaires,
but both the commanders and the troops lacked the experience of their opponents
as can a Hannibal painted a masterpiece in Roman blood,
a total and perfect and sacrament of the enemy army as it cost the Ginny in
general placed his troops in a slightly convex formation rather than the
traditional line is advanced troops at the center.
First go to the room and sent it to advance. Then slowly withdrew as they did.
So the wings of the formation surrounded the Roman legions from both sides,
finally,
animals cavalry attacked from the rear preventing any chance to run away.
The trap closed as the youth of Rome was annihilated by the Carthaginian meat
grinder. Many of the army leaders died including console immediacy,
Polis 48,000 Legionnaires fell to their enemies.
And that's the most conservative number.
The mortality rate has been estimated to be 500 deaths per minute,
and this will more than 90 minutes.
Roman lost more men in battle than Canada did. And the whole of world war two,
or almost as many men as the U S in 10 years of war in Vietnam.
Puberty has Cornelius Skipio Jr.
Was that as a 19 year old Tribune or junior officer,
we don't have an account of what he did during the battle.
We only know what he did afterward while the surviving Legionnaires and offices
were in shock, confused as to what to do. Booby has displayed great leadership.
The young officer rounded up a group of survivors and led them to safety past
Hannibal's men, still looking for survivors monitoring in silence at night,
always leading the way to look for the safest route. Previous letters,
bands to the safety of kind of see him while on the run.
People is interviewed as men trying to understand what had caused such a
disaster. How could an army be crushed?
So decisively by studying the battles,
Skipio started to develop a admiration for Hannibal shore general barcode was
his enemy, but poop. I would also consider him as his model, his master,
and as we know, the destiny of every pupil is to one day, pass them all.
Step off to the victory of Kenai Hannibal's army.
Let's take the initiative to storm Ryan preferring to rest and Kapoor.
30 kilometers North of Naples.
Legend has it that the Senate sent a special force, a 300 dedicated Romans,
just all their movements, not 300 Spartan hoplites,
but 300 prostitutes whose sole job was to keep Hannibal soldiers busy,
whatever the truth,
the Carthaginian force did waste some time gallivanting and Capoeira.
And later they occupied Southern Italy foraging on supplies and gradually
gaining new regional allies.
Hannibal may have had a long-term strategy to weaken Rome until he forced to
surrender,
but he had underestimated the strength of the bonds between the Roman Senate and
the Roman people. This was a bond of trust,
which not even at 500 deaths a minute could dissolve some allies may have
switched sides. Sure,
but others perpetuated that allegiance to Rome and room resistant.
If we now zoom into the Senate, we may find Skipio junior. Again,
it's 213 BC and Skipio is 22 years old since can.
He had married a Mia daughter of Amelia's Polis,
the console who had died in that battle.
The couple later have three children previous the third Lucius and Cornelia,
excuse me.
His reputation for courage and leadership at accelerated is cost us on aura.
The ladder of public officers needing to the console ship.
People who are senior would have been proud of him that he'd been there while
Hannibal had been plundering Southern Italy,
the sentence that adopted a wise strategy,
attack him to re-ask the Carthaginian allies in Spain.
So we can them meant cut them off from supplies.
The Senate had dispatched previous senior and his brother Nilus to take care of
the Iberian tribes in 211 BC, a massive Iberian Carthaginian force a tank.
The Romans on the bitus river, the Romans were repelled back.
As far as Northeastern Spain,
this defeat was compounded by a personal tragedy for Publius junior,
both his father and his uncle had been killed in battle like his Carthaginian
foil. The struggle had now become personal.
The sending needed to appoint a new commander,
a broader pro console to continue the campaign in Spain.
Puberty has cornea Skipio barely 25 was elected almost unanimously to lead the
expedition. Of course, he accepted to avenge Rome, his family,
his father Skipio appointed Kayas Lelea as the second in command,
a trusted right-hand man from Israelian military days,
the to sell it off to terracotta modern day Tarragona to take charge of the
surviving legions.
The first act of the young general was to motivate those veterans,
to do the unthinkable rather than entrenched themselves on the river Ebro,
as they expected, they would attack their enemies in central and Southern Spain.
As his armies crossed the river. Skipio revealed his true objective.
The city on the Southeastern coast, the very Capitol of the enemy in Spain.
[Inaudible].
The military theorists,
clean them AZELLA and his MacLaughlin have analyzed Skipio strategy from the
perspective of the center of gravity battle theory,
which goals for the identification and destruction of the true center of an
enemy, armies strength or balance Hallowell center of gravity was the support he
received from Spain and Spain center of gravity was new Carthage noon to be
impregnable surrounded on three sides by the sea and lagoon.
It could be besieged only by a narrow isthmus, but the crafty Skipio questions,
some local fishermen who told him about the tides,
which at specific times were so low,
that one could walk across the lagoon exploiting this natural occurrence.
Skipio announced to his soldiers,
that he would part the waters with the help of Neptune God of the sea.
And to the expected time the sea did withdraw from the lagoon that contingent
rushed a new cartilage and storms, the poorly defended walls.
After the victory yell out his troops to pillage and slaughter for a brief
period. But then he imposed strict discipline.
Some of the prisoners belonged to the same tribes that had killed his father,
but he released them all. He went one step further offering artisans, sailors,
and soldiers, a chance to join the ranks of the Romans. After this Congress,
Skipio out to square off with the three Carthaginian generals and Iberia
Hannibal's younger brothers have Struble and megas baka,
and [inaudible] Hannibal's brother-in-law the next engagement with the enemy was
the battle of Bay cooler, some 350 kilometers West of new Carthage and 208 BC.
Skipio used a signature pencil tactic for the first time.
He divided his main forces into two strong wings,
which fell upon the Carthaginians flanks. After the victory Skipio showed again,
his pension for long sighted clemency.
When he learns that a new Midian horseman called MES Eva had been made prisoner.
He ordered his release.
The young soldier was a nephew of mass Anissa Prince at the Eastern new Midians
who would later show his gratitude.
The next big fight took place in 206 BC at a leper near modern day Seville.
This was [inaudible] Shawn's to wipe the floor with Megace Barker and
[inaudible] during this battle,
Skipio took another step further away from the Roman tactical tradition.
A typical order of battle would be to field the heavy Roman infantry at the
center of a law nine flying Splunk lighter auxiliary force is provided by local.
Yeah, the Carthaginians at a similar approach,
but to deliberate Skipio did exactly the opposite is Liberian allies forms the
center bearing the shock of the advance of heavily armed conflict Genia and
foot. As the Iberian Solie was drew the well drilled Roman legions advanced in a
pencil movement,
crushing their opponents guesses and test rubles armies risked annihilation.
If it wasn't for a violent and timely downfall,
the Southern bad weather prevented the rooms from chasing their enemies.
You managed to run for their lives.
That must have been disappointed for Skipio nonetheless. It,
it appeared as though the reigns of a Lipper had washed away the remnants of
Carthaginian power in Spain history. Bulger's go fled back to Carthage. Well,
Meg is baka. So refuge and the ballistic islands,
their local allies had switched sides to Rome and Skipio had made some powerful
new friends.
Prince mass runs his legendary Numidian horseman at the young age of 29.
General skier had subjugated and new province Hispania for the glory of Rome.
But the fight was far from over in the same year.
Ski made a quick trip to Northern Africa to test the loyalty of catheters.
As allies in particular, the Western Indians,
he learns that the King Syphax was tied into the Carthaginians by marriage.
His wife, the beautiful Syphon ball was the daughter of
[inaudible] friends. Messiness.
There was the Prince of the Eastern Midians while both mass Anissa and Syphax
had been fighting on the Carthaginian side.
They were at odds with each other politically.
They both vined for total leadership of the United Namibians on a more personal
level. Massiveness has long been in love with Stephan,
the newly out of his rival. During this trip,
Skipio failed to turn the Western the Midians against Carthage,
but he cemented the Alliance with mass Anissa boosting both numbers and the
quality of his cavalry. Excuse me. As next trip was back home, back to Rome,
he received a hero's welcome. And in 205 BC,
he won the console ship aged only 30 Skipio wanted to continue leading the war
against Hannibal who was still holding on to Southern Italy.
He was presented with two options,
either confront Hannibal head on initially with the risk of a second disaster,
like Kenai or continue with the delaying tactics imposed by Quintus fabulous
Maximus nicknames.
The delayer Maximus was the senior most Senator who for years,
it supported the strategy of harassing Hannibal's army to wear them down without
giving into a full-on battle. Skipio chose.
None of the above his strategy was to set up a base of operations in Sicily and
use it as a launching pad for the invasion of Africa,
a direct fight against her Hannibal was still too dangerous,
but he could destroy him by targeting another center of gravity.
Skipio had already taken out the center that had been providing Hannibal with
recruits and supplies in Spain. Now he would target the center of his house.
Authority, Carthage.
The Roman Senate influenced by Maximus opposed this command and conquer
strategy. It was too expensive and too risky historian.
Giovanni Brizzy also suggests that the family of the layout may have had trade
ties with the Carthaginian senators.
It was not in their interest to threaten the wealth of their trade partners.
Eventually Skipio wins. The Senate reached a compromise.
He had permission to carry out his plan,
but he could not raise fresh legions for his African landing.
All Skipio received with the survivors of canape.
These soldiers were the republics rejects, defeated and demoralized,
humiliated and mistrusted by their own compatriots accused of cowardice and
desertion.
These two Meagan agents had been refreshed with elements from disciplinary
units, soldiers, guilty of insubordination theft and other crimes.
But the young general would not allow himself to fail.
He drilled into shape his dirty dozen or dirty 10 thousands,
and then launched an appeal to the attack allies.
The allies responded to his calls, sending money, food, weapons, raw material,
to build new ships and even hundreds of fully kitted out soldiers.
Before heading off to Northern Africa,
Skipio put his troops to the test in the invasion of lock rape.
The Southern Italian town had highlighted itself to Hannibal,
but Skipio spies informed him, but the tide was turning. The general,
took the occasion to send a landing party,
which promptly storms the town and surprise night attack chasing away the
Carthaginian Garrison.
This victory risked ruining all of Scorpios Grant's plans.
The three officers left in charge at lottery proved to be a gang of crooks.
They terrorized the local population and even desecrated the temple of the main
data. The goddess pro subpoena Maximus took the occasion to cry scandal.
He asked for mosquitoes returned to Romans for a commission of inquiry to
investigate the events of lottery. Luckily,
the general soon had some friends in the Senate and they snuck a cousin of his,
into the commission to act in his stead. The trick works as the final report,
exonerated Skipio from any wrongdoing where the internal opposition taking care
of Skipio was now free to launch his invasion. In the summer of 204,
he set sail from Sicily leading an army of 23,500 foot and
2,500 cavalryman. In other words, 26,000 men,
the same number that Hannibal had led into Italy years before near coincidence,
or maybe Skipio was once again,
proving that he could study emulate and eventually best his enemy Skipio and his
army reached the first objective in Northern Africa.
The city of Vertica on the coast of what is today, Tunisia,
the Romans were seen besieged by two armies.
The Namibians led by Syphax and Carthaginian mercenaries under how Struble
Giscard exploiting his previous acquaintance with the Numidian King.
Skipio sent ambassadors to discuss a peace settlement.
This may have been against character,
but Skipio could recognize when he was in a difficult spot.
The talks continued until the beginning of 203 BC when Syphax and Skipio reached
a compromise,
Rome would retain control of Sicily and Sardinia while Carthage would rule over
the remaining islands of the Western Mediterranean King side effects relished
his diplomatic skills. One night in March, he prepared to relax in his lodging,
surrounded by us from middle Alami that spent months inside of a makeshift camp
of wooden barracks. But the war was finally coming to an end,
a cry disturbed his peace as a cool spread wild among the centuries PLA
in a matter of minutes,
nearly the entire nymity in camp was ablaze with furious flames, consuming,
the tents and cabins made of twigs and dry branches.
The soldiers drive to escape the Inferno only to be quickly cut down by devils
hiding in the dock. Messiness is Holsman and ski BEOS band of rejects.
What just happens while conducting talks with cyphass Skipio who had sent some
of his offices to the enemy camp to size as messengers, all sevens,
the officers spied on the new Midians taking note of the centuries,
their shifts,
and especially on the flammable nature of the camp off the side effects of load
is God Skipio that sent his two most trusted deputies.
Massiveness are in Kaya's lay-leaders is to set the camp on fire while the
Numidian army was slaughtered at detachment left from the nearby Ford of house
dribble justice Skipio would plans the cultive Jeanine's work coming to help
their allies and just escape. You had plans gives, goes,
forces were ambushed and massacred on the way that out of the flames of Vertica
Scorpios rejects image triumphant,
this was their first big victory in enemy territory,
but something also emerged from the ashes,
a new style of warfare previously inconceivable to the Romans,
a tactical doctrine founded on strategy, ENS, ambushes, and traps.
It was yet another lesson learned from Hannibal. Some of the Thunderbolt,
one at Skipio son of the serpent could not wait to turn against his master.
[Inaudible].
Dribble and side effects managed to escape or to cope with support from his own
Senate general guests go raised another mercenary army.
These new units blocked the weight Carthage by holding positions on the fields
along the river, but gratis Skipio marched.
Head-on ready to meet the enemy and a pitched battle.
Skipio ordered his men to take the most traditional formation of the Republican
times three lines of infantry protected by two wings cavalry.
The first line weather has starty young and fit soldiers to carry out the first
clash with the enemy. The second line where the Principia is older Legionnaires,
finally, the tree Ari,
the reserve of battle-hardened veterans who would join the fray at the time of
need, uh,
started his battle by launching his Calvary into action with a lady is on the
rise of mass or on the left. So they challenged at discos horseman.
The attack was successful in the conflict unions, retreated, alias,
and mass Inessa continued to chase. And when the dust settles,
the flanks of disco's infantry were completely exposed and it was time to crush
them.
The Prince of bees and [inaudible] would normally fight in long compacts lines,
supporting the starti. But now scape,
you had split them into smaller agile mandibles this way.
They carry downs and enveloping maneuver,
squeezing the enemies and a giant Pensa scape.
You had evolved animals in circumvent tactic and to one that was much deadlier
and quicker to execute. Another Carthaginian army had been destroyed. This time,
guests go inside, thanks had fallen, captive nothing,
and nobody stood in the way of Carthage.
There was nothing left to do for its Senate,
but start another round of peace talks during the winter of 203 and 200 and TBC
Skipio imposed conditions that respected the integrity and sovereignty of
Carthage and its African territories.
The Carthage had to recognize mass Anissa as the sole King of the United
Namibians,
the city out to withdraw its troops from Italy and abandon any plans returned to
Spain.
The Carthaginian Senate was also forced to disband the Naval fleet and mercenary
forces and to pay an immense sum of 5,000 silver talents to Rome.
[Inaudible].
Peace negotiated with Carthage proved to be short-lived the shipment of food
supplies intended for the Roman army.
It was blown off course by strong winds and the triremes were beach Carthage,
hungry citizens,
plundered the ships and refuse to return that loot Skipio took the occasion to
resume hostilities devastating the farmlands around Carthage.
Was he just looking for an excuse to continue the fights until Hannibal showed
up? Well,
this latest action did cause Hannibal to return before Skipio could strike at
Carthage.
Annabelle blocked his path by establishing a camp in Zana Hannibal's remaining
army matched the Romans in strength at about 40,000 troops.
Plus he had the elephants, you had less coverage DPO,
and then realized perhaps too late,
that Zimmer was not well supplied with fresh water.
Annabel could not endure a long standoff and he needed a way out.
His first initiative was to ask for a meeting with Skipio to perhaps negotiate a
truce or resume talks for a definitive piece.
We don't have an exact record of their meeting.
What we do know is that the two greatest generals of their age showed the
deepest respect to each other. Perhaps Skipio was all struck by the old arrival.
And perhaps Hannibal was amused to meet a younger foe who clearly considered him
to be a master. When Hannibal trying to propose the truce,
however Skipio was unmoved. He replied you fail to endure peace.
You must now prepare for war on October, the 19th, 202 BC,
the serpents and the funds have all faced each other at Zimmer.
The battle that would end it all one way or the other Scioto arranged as men in
columns,
leaving wide corridors between the manacles and the gaps were covered by a line
of light infantry. Hannibal had placed his war, elephants at the front,
since he started the battle by unleashing them on the Romans.
This is exactly what Skipio expected.
He ordered his front lines to bang their drums and blew their trumpets as loud
as they could producing such noise that frightens the elephants,
that stampeded back to the Carthaginians decimated in that front lines.
Some elephants continued their forward charge.
This is when Scorpio's light inventory moved out of the way,
revealing the gaps between the mandibles.
The elephants continue to charge along the corridors,
doing this all damage and eventually leaving the battle.
Now Skipio took the initiative,
the audit [inaudible] and cause Linnaeus to attack the Carthaginian horseman,
protecting Hannibal's flanks,
the Romans and Midians since the better cavalry ans were able to chase off their
opponents. Finally,
it was time for Skipio to unleashes Pensa and surround Hannibal the Roman
seconds and third lines of inventory moved it out to the sides,
ready to suffocate the Carthaginians with a mortal embrace.
But Hannibal that heard about the battle that the gratis and knew what to expect
as the Romans tried to move around their enemy.
The Carthaginians spread out in a long line, preventing them sacrament.
This was the perfect countermove. Now it was just a long line of Roman infantry,
opposite along line of Carthaginians and allies with covering out the picture of
scapegoats. Infantry were outnumbered and could have quickly broken ranks,
but they didn't. Those Legionnaires were the veterans of Kenai,
the former reject stunned heroes at the Republic.
This was their occasion to avenge their defeat and they would not back down.
Eventually the Carthaginians started to news cohesion,
some messenger units try to retreat fighting their own allies to shove them out
of the way. But the final blow came from mass Nyssa,
an alias like an easterly winds.
The cavalry's gallops back to the Malai striking the Carthaginians from
behind Annabel managed to escape.
But on that day he left 20,000 of his men on the grounds,
along with any remaining hope of saving Carthage Rome, and Skipio.
I'd won the war.
Leah Skipio returns a room in triumph. He was now addressed as Afrikaners.
Thanks to his splendid victories, Northern Africa.
Skipio negotiated a very good peace deal for Rome.
Carthage retained its possessions in Africa,
but it became a client state of the Roman Republic.
Carthage would also pan indemnity of 10,000 silver talents, renounce orbit,
10 of its Naval vessels and all of its war elephants. During his campaign,
Skipio had also won a new ally to Rome, new media.
It also conquered a whole new province.
Hispania the first Roman controlled territory outside of Italy.
Skipio was young, powerful, influential, and wealthy.
His agents loved him to the point of swearing allegiance to him rather than
Rome.
This aroused the suspicion of the Senate to the more conservative senators.
This man was dangerous.
What could prevent him from declaring himself King and returning to the days of
Roman monarchy.
Rome was a Republic and she intended to remain one the occasion to strike it.
Skipio came some years later in 194 BC King and Yonkers.
Third of Syria was threatening the Greek city States,
which at the time were under room's protection.
His chief military advisor was none other than Hannibal Skipio at the time was
strongly opposed by his most vocal political rival Marcus pokey,
as Carto better known as Carter, the older,
but the presence of Hannibal in Syria,
alums enough of the Senate to allow for Skipio to retake the position of
console. Once again,
let's give you left room for a diplomatic mission in Greece,
Syria than Asia minor. According to some sources,
you have the occasion to meet Hannibal during the trip,
the two chatted like old friends, talking history and strategy.
Skipio asked Hannibal who he thought were the three greatest strategists,
the devil lift, Hannibal replied Alexander, the great Paris and myself.
Skip. You had another question,
but what would you have said if you had conquered me Hannibal replied,
I should then have said that I was greater than Alexander greater than Paris and
greater than all other generals. The war with Syria eventually broke out.
Skipio joined in 190 BC is nominal deputy to his brother Lucius.
Unfortunately the two old foods did not meet again. Hannibal was in Phoenicia,
raising a fleet for the Syrians and had been pinned down by the Navy of roads,
allied to Rome in January of 189,
BC Lucia Skipio defeated the Syrians and the battle of magnesium as older
brother Publius was away from the battlefield, recovering from an illness,
but he was the victim. At least in spirit,
as Lucius had used his tactics and command legions that he had raised and
trained himself after magnesia can Antioch sued for peace,
agreeing to a payment of 15,000 silver talents to Rome of these,
he paid an advance of 500 to the Scorpios.
Africa has used this money for his private expenses,
maybe to pay his soldiers wages. This is still not clear.
What mattered is that he had spent that money without asking permission from the
Senate. This was the occasion that Skipio his rivals fronted by Conte.
The elder were waiting for, he put the Skipio brothers on trial twice.
The first time in 187 BC Lucius was asked to produce the accounting ledger for
the Syrian expedition,
but Afrikanas intervened and tore it to pieces in front of the Senate.
He then reminded them that he was being tried on the anniversary of his victory
at Zama.
The outcry was such that contract contented himself with a [inaudible] find
solution at the second trial in 184,
BC Carter accused scape you of embezzlement corruption and even planning to
become King of Rome with a military coup this time Carter was vetoed from
further prosecuting the general bite Senator Tiberias Gracos the elder.
He was later Mary Skipio, his only daughter Cornelia.
Despite these victories in court,
Skipio had grown disgusted with the Roman political class.
It was not willing to serve the Republic anymore. And so he retired to his farm.
I'd listened them their Naples one day,
a crew of pirates lands that listen to them and the old general prepared to face
them weapons. In hands soon,
he realized that the pirates are not coming to burn and loot.
They only wanted to meet the famous Victor of Zama such was the,
of Skipio throughout the ancient Mediterranean world and 183 BC Skipio.
Must've heard the news. This in the lens of Bethany,
Hannibal had committed suicide by poison.
He had been vilified for his defeated Zimmer and forced to fleet Carthage,
serving foreign Kings while escaping captured by the Romans that same year and
183 BC, the greatest general room had ever gnomes to come to an illness.
It was most likely malaria Publius Cornelius Skipio Africanas closed his eyes
and joins many friends and enemies in the Elysian fields. And as well,
he asked for his bones to be buried away from the ungrateful room.
Skipio his legacy was enormous.
His approach to strategy and innovative tactics revolutionized the armies of the
Republic.
His conquests launched the expansion of Rome beyond the confines of Italy.
His defeat of Carthage made the Romans a sea of power unrivaled in the
Mediterranean and as the cult of loyalty among his men and legions created a
precedence for the emergence of characters like Julius Caesar and Augustus and
shores,
the life and achievements of Skipio Afrikanas were a major turning point in
which the history of the Republic became it was the downhill slope toward an
empire. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that arms up button below. Don't forget to subscribe.
Thank you for watching.